les etats unis tentent une nouvelle fois
d'extrader julian assange après un
premier échec en janvier le sort du
fondateur de wikileaks est actuellement
entre les mains de la haute cour de
londres on retrouve notre envoyé spécial
au royaume-uni 4 ça pique nique bonsoir
garcia julian assange qui n'a donc pas
assisté à l'audience il avait pris un
médicament qui le rendait incapable de
suivre le procès mais il est apparu très
brièvement en vision escorté donc pas
ringarde
et oui c'est cela stéphanie tout à fait
alors comme il est apparu très amaigri
am émacié étrangers bien c'était un
signal très inquiétant pour ses soutiens
qui se sont regroupés aujourd'hui
le poids que le juge barry soeur à
donner aux professeurs kopelman étaient
exagérées l'accusation n'a pas été en
mesure de mettre en lumière les faits et
elle a également été trompeuses pour la
cour et pourtant il y avait eu beaucoup
de considération de certains aspects de
tous les rapports de tous les
psychiatres dans le jugement du juge
marie soeur que julian ne soit pas
extradé
johanna
psa quels arguments juridiques ont été
amenés
oui alors vous l'avez entendu par la
bouche du père de julian assange donc
ils ont cherché à discréditer le rapport
d'expertisé du psychiatre inquiète un
grand nom un de la psychiatrie est du
domaine juridique et qu'ils étaient
favorables à julian assange pourquoi
favorable parce que il évoquait un
risque suicidaire très fort et sous
prétexte qu'il ne mentionnait pas à ce
rapport la présence d'une compagnie et
de deux enfants est bien les états unis
ont pu faire appel alors aujourd'hui le
représentant des américains auprès de la
cour james lewis appuyé sur plusieurs
points notamment diplomatiques c'est un
peu l'enjeu de ce procès en affirmant
que la grande bretagne avait jusqu'ici a
pas eu à se plaindre de sa longue
coopération avec les américains et
surtout il a affirmé que les états unis
donneraient des assurances comme par
exemple celle de ne pas m julian assange
à l'isolément et pourtant les documents
officiels qui sont produits montre bien
que les états unis peuvent se réserver
le droit d'imposer des restrictions donc
par exemple isolement donc ce n'est pas
vraiment un argument qui tient et puis
bien sûr ce représentant a contesté la
décision de janvier est de la juge
estimant qu'elle avait mal jugé des
éléments concernant la santé mentale
détérioré de julian assange alors ces
arguments ont été très rapidement contré
par l'équipe de défense de julian
assange qui explique au contraire la
juge avait fait des choix scrupuleux et
qu'il y avait un risque de suicides
évidents et qu'en fait les américains
n'ont trouvé aucune erreur légale dans
la procédure et qu'ils ont fait appel
juste parce qu'ils avaient échoué en
première instance et je vous propose
maintenant d'écouter lors il a voulu
c'est un hacker britannique qui a fait
comme dylan assange l'objet d'une
demande d'extradition des etats-unis
pour exactement les mêmes raisons qui a
vécu un véritable cauchemar
nous avons perdu dans le premier cas
contrairement à julian qui a gagné mais
doit encore attendre un appel ici et
c'était un procès sur les mêmes bases
mais il serait injuste et oppressif de
soumettre quelques uns aux mêmes
conditions auxquelles j'ai été où
seraient confrontés
alors stéphanie le programme de demain
c'est que l'équipe de julian assange va
s'employer à démonter l'argumentaire
américain et une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation se prépare devant la haute
cour aujourd'hui il y avait environ 500
personnes qui se sont relayés les un
concert des prises de parole à stella
mauricien la compagne de jay and assange
qui a parlé de persécutions politiques y
avait des représentants également de
reporters sans frontières est donc une
deuxième journée encore de soutien a dû
à un échange de main et on vous suivra
évidemment demain katia allons pouvoir
les derniers développements merci
également aujourd'hui demory qui vous
accompagnent derrière la caméra 4